[Musique]
demain que le grand défi qu'on continue
d'avoir s'est trouvé le moyen d'attirer
d'amener du personnel additionnel en
avril 2020 le gouvernement crée un
débordement du réseau il lance un appel
pressant à tous ces travailleurs de la
santé nous anges gardiens comme les a
appelés
puis nos zouk salsa essentielle on va en
avoir de besoins maximum donc on va te
faire pour les protéger
[Musique]
je veux me souvenir toute ma ville d'une
réunion ou à mordelles et le mes
collègues aux 1000 points sa table candy
lefrançois faut faire quelque chose de
sa pote bon sens tout le monde tombent
comme des mouches
à première vue c'est une personne sur
quatre qui avaient la coved qui est d'un
travailleur de la santé
mais moi je pense qu'on aurait dû mettre
tout ce qui était possible de mettre en
place pour essayer d'améliorer ou de
réduire dans le fond l'exposition par
inhalation du travail selon des experts
les autorités auraient pu mieux prendre
soin de leur ange gardien
au coeur du débat un masque le n95
[Musique]
on continue à communiquer que le masque
médical et un équivalent alors que ce
n'est pas comme ça jamais été le corps
puis joie par jour où ça va être le cas
ces spécialistes se bat depuis un an au
sein de l'appareil gouvernemental pour
élargir l'accès au n95
selon eux ce masque devait protéger
contre risque sous-estimé la
transmission par aérosol
mais ils ont été largement ignorés ou
censurés
[Musique]
c'est l'appel de monsieur legault qui a
lancé l'appel d'écouter les médecins on
a besoin de vous on a besoin de votre
aide pour aider j'ai compris que peu
importe ce que j'allais faire on avait
besoin de ma présence fait que je me
suis mangé
j'embarque la docteure mélanie roy est
une chirurgienne ophtalmologiste de
montréal en avril 2020 elle décide de se
porter volontaires quelques jours plus
tard elle est parachutée au ch clp qui
vont brûler à verdun elle atterrit au
milieu d'une des pires éclosion au
québec on voyait très bien qu avait un
besoin criant de dead beaucoup de décès
à tous les jours des décès je voyais
aussi que même les gens s'ils sont plus
habitués non parce qu'ils travaillent
avec des gens plus âgés mais sous le
choc de voir partir autant de gens aussi
rapidement mais ceux qui les soignent
aussi tombe malade
quand on était frappé nous par la
première vague c'était 80 heures semaine
pendant ces semaines de file car on va
donner mais chacun est arrivé au bout de
son rouleau où ils étaient contaminés
donc il était vote serré le docteur
françois piot aux pratiques en gériatrie
et en soins palliatifs à québec à la
même période
il mène aussi un combat épuisant contre
une éclosion qui décime l'hôpital
jeffery elle sait quand on est au
travail qu'on est le plus utile c'est
pas quand on est malade chez nous ou
sait pas quand des gens quittent la
profession parce que ils n'en peuvent
plus quand j'ai compris qu'on était
protégé seulement avec le masque de
procédure je devenu très pessimiste
quant à la possibilité de ne pas
l'attraper
mélanie roy veut apporter de chez elle
un masque de type n 95
la réponse était formelle non la
position avait été répété à plusieurs
reprises et assez assez durement les
gestionnaires la sueur que le masque de
procédure et sécuritaire selon les
experts de la santé publique les n95 lui
explique-t-on sont rationnées est
réservé à des interventions médicales
générant des aérosols comme les
intubations et enfin ce ne serait pas
juste pour les autres employés
la dr oits continuent à travailler mais
ça n 95 je pense pas que beaucoup de
métiers dans lesquels on accepterait que
les gens aillent travailler en ayant
peur mais là c'est ce qui se passe dans
le domaine de la santé
les gens comparent je vais vous dire la
vérité pour certains équipements on en
or pour trois à sept jours
donc quand même serré il ne fait aucun
doute qu'il y a eu pénurie de matériel
médical au printemps
pourtant en 2009 le québec avait selon
nos informations une réserve de 12
millions de m 95
mais ces stocks ont été écoulés ou sont
devenus péri mais ils n'ont jamais été
renouvelé les autorités maintiennent
toutefois que ce n'est pas la pénurie
qui explique l'accès restreint au n95
c'est que la majorité des travailleurs
n'ont pas besoin ces réponses le était
toujours que donc tant que ce n'est pas
prouvée puis que le mode principal les
ports la transmission par inhalation ben
on en a pas besoin
comment se transmet lakovic 19 le débat
fait rage depuis le début de la pandémie
pour la santé publique
elle s'attrape par des gouttelettes
assez grosse lors d'un contact de moins
de deux mètres et la transmission par
aérosol n'intervient que rarement lors
d'interventions médicales génératrice
d'aérosols les iem géant
dans l'autre camp on parle plutôt d'un
ensemble de bio aérosols de différentes
tailles qui peuvent demeurer en
suspension voyager et être inhalées pour
se protéger le masque médical est
insuffisant il faut un respirateur comme
le n95 bien ajustés qui évite les fuites
présente pas faut pas penser qu'ils
agissent au québec où on a de la
difficulté à bien définir le mode de
transmission c'est vraiment un débat
mondial la microbiologiste et
biochimiste geneviève marchand et dans
le deuxième quart si on peut voir sur
l'écran justement les cantines de
différentes particules selon leur
grosseur qui sont mesurés à l'institut
de recherche robert-sauvé en santé et
sécurité du travail qui y est resté
elle mène des recherches sur les bio
aérosols depuis 2003 l'année où le monde
a eu un avant-goût de cette pandémie
avec le strass santé canada prend très
au sérieux les menaces que fait planer
une mystérieuse forme de pneumonie
venus d'asie au canada ce virus a frappé
toronto et soulever les mêmes débats
gouttelettes aérosols une commission d'
enquête avait conclu que les
travailleurs de la santé n'avait pas été
assez protégé à l'époque le québec tente
d'en tirer des leçons
pourquoi on n'applique pas ce qu'on
avait retenu pour le strass et en 2003
le docteur littéraire a co rédigé ce
rapport
ce débat là est l'homme nous au québec
on l'avait réglé justement parce qu'on
avait toutes les disciplines réunis et
on avait convenu que le masque médical
n'est pas une option
même sans certitudes scientifiques le
rapport recommandait des masques comme
les n 95 pour les soignants en contact
avec le virus
par principe de précaution
c'est ce principe qui va opposer en 2020
les organismes de santé publique et de
santé et sécurité au travail
la chercheuse geneviève marchand va se
sentir censuré au début début de la
pandémie c'était un avis qui traitait de
l'émission des particules justement un
peu des modes de transmission par
inhalation dans laquelle l'ailier rester
recommande effectivement dans cette
ville à la part du un appareil de
protection respiratoire pour les
travailleurs de la santé qui étaient les
plus exposées
si un avis qui est pas resté sur le site
web le 8 avril 2020 il y est resté
publiés en ligne
une de ces fiches techniques pour guider
le gouvernement durant cette pandémie
une fiche sur les appareils de
protection respiratoire comme le n95 à
l'origine dit geneviève marchand le
petit paragraphe suivant obtenu par
enquêtes s'y trouvaient seuls les
appareils de protection respiratoire
permettent de protéger les travailleurs
contre les risques d'inhalation débit
aux aérosols
mais très rapidement dit elle il va
disparaître de la fiche compétent sur le
site web dans cette étude
cinq minutes ah oui à peu près pile
vous savez possible pourquoi où on m'a
appelé pour me dire qu'ils laissent la
vie était disparu parce qu'il ya des
gens qui étaient très déçus mais le
pourquoi du comment on mon projet on ne
peut expliquer le pourquoi
petit moment de malaise avec la
représentante des communications qui est
dans la salle
s'il avait été publié l'avis de la
microbiologiste aurait contredit la
position officielle du gouvernement
est ce pour cette raison qu'on l'a
retirée il y est resté nous a d'abord
répondu que la ville n'avait pas été
mise en ligne
mais nous avons appris qu'il a été
brièvement raison officielle la preuve
scientifique n'était pas jugée assez
robuste mais deux jours après le retrait
du paragraphe la pdg de liens attestés
juge que la preuve est suffisamment
solide pour qu'elle transmette un avis
semblable à celui de geneviève marchand
à l'organisme qui gère la santé et
sécurité au travail
la cns est et c'est ce que nous avons
appris grâce à une demande d'accès à
l'information
pourquoi cette contradiction entre les
positions internes et externes de lire
assister nous n'avons pas reçu de
réponse à cette question
mais selon des sources des débats
houleux sur les n 95 ont lieu durant
cette période entre la santé publique et
la cnss thé à laquelle est rattachée
l'institut de geneviève marchand
car ça fait longtemps que tu cherches
sur un domaine quand tu es passionné par
tant de domaines quand tu y crois
profondément que tu penses que tes
connaissances sont suffisantes pour
faire des bonnes recommandations
qu'elles ne sont pas nécessairement
suivi pour pas vous le cacher oui ça a
été assez difficile
le 1er mai deux semaines après avoir
commencé à travailler aussi à celle d
yvon brunelle la docteure mélanie roy
contracte lakovic 19
c'est vraiment venu me chercher ce qui
s'est passé parce que tout d'un coup je
me suis sentie comme comme si je dépends
importantes comme si on on se
préoccupait pas assez de la situation et
je peux très bien voir que les autres
travailleurs aussi ressentez ça
durant la première vague près de 14000
travailleurs de la santé ont contracté
la coved 19
le quart des victimes du virus dans la
province onze travailleurs sont décédés
ils ont été vraiment des héros toute la
nation québécoise leur doit
reconnaissance
[Musique]
la ville de québec sous le couvre fric
des airs de ville abandonnée irréel dans
sa fin dans une deuxième vague
la première vague c'est de la petite
bière par rapport à la luz à plus de 38
l'autre soignants vont contracter
lakovic 19 pour la plupart d'entre eux
toujours 100 m 95
le docteur libérèrent a tout fait pour
que le gouvernement change d'avis et ce
spécialiste en médecine du travail avec
la santé publique de la
capitale-nationale n'hésite pas à sortir
du rang dans la première vague les
travailleurs de la santé avait un risque
dix fois plus élevé que la population
générale
donc il y avait et il quelque chose de
déficients depuis le début ils
interpellent les autorités pour qu'elles
fournissent plus de masques de type n 95
aux travailleurs de la santé sans succès
durant l'été le docteur bert à
travailler avec des chercheurs pour
faire des échantillonnages de l'air et
des surfaces dans des zones rouges
d'établissement de québec des immeubles
souvent vieillot et mal ventilée ces
résultats n'ont rendu public long à
l'armée on le trouvait de la rn giral
sud sur le haut des cadres de porte à 4
mai du patient
les particules étaient transportés par
l'est bien plus loin les soignants qui
viennent dans la chambre du patient
ben avec un masque ibai par les côtés
sont susceptibles d inhaler il reconnaît
que la science n'a pas encore prouvé que
ces particules de virus peuvent infecter
les gens mais selon lui le risque existe
vous avez transmis les résultats plat
synthèse aux autorités concernées oui
aux autorités ministérielles ministériel
de devenir directeur de santé publique
il répond non donc ni aux lettres ni aux
études de caractérisation le docteur
arruda étaient déjà partis dans une
direction totalement opposé le 8 juin il
émet une ordonnance qui interdit les n95
en dehors des iem ga les interventions
médicales générant des aérosols luc
bérard et son collègue françois pius
sont consternés quand j'ai plus
connaissance de leur donnant d'abord je
me suis je m'étonnais ça limitait un
dumas le drouais des ddd des
travailleurs
appréciez un danger faut se poser la
question pourquoi on est la seule
juridiction en amérique du nord et dans
le monde à ma connaissance
pourquoi on a senti le besoin de de dire
non seulement la résidence
scientifiquement le recommande pas mais
on l'interdît cetc questionnant si elle
mettant le problème est un problème
d'approvisionnement bien qu'on met la
[ __ ] au fond puis qu'on n'en
produisent au plus vite pour contre
capable après c'est à dire bon mais là
les données ce cumul on en or go on y va
les syndicats ont entrepris des
démarches judiciaires pour forcer le
gouvernement à élargir l'accès au n95
c'est comme ça que nous avons appris qu
après la première vague le gouvernement
n'a pas tenté d'élargir son petit bassin
de fournisseurs au mois de juin
le pire de la pénurie était passé a
déclaré le sous ministre adjoint de la
santé luc des biens et les stocks
étaient adéquats pour usage de n95
permis dans le réseau
d'autant plus que le ministère savait
qu'il allait recevoir au printemps 2021
des millions de ces n95 d'une nouvelle
usine à ville saint-laurent entre temps
pour diminuer les risques en vue de la
deuxième vague
le gouvernement cherche ailleurs chute à
nouveau par l'hygiène des mains
fête populaire l'hôpital notre dame de
montréal des travailleurs suivent une
formation pour apprendre à utiliser de
façon sécuritaire les équipements de
protection des formations devenue
routinière dans le réseau ces efforts
ont entraîné une réduction du taux
d'infection mais il reste encore
supérieur à la moyenne canadienne et il
est le double de celui de l'ontario où
les infirmières ont pu demander des n95
en novembre à québec une éclosion éclate
dans un ch et celle d où travaille le
docteur pius cette fois ils l'attrapent
vue dans la nuit je me suis réveillé
puis je frissonnais re puis donc des
clans pour moi j'allais passer mon test
j'ai eu le résultat
comment je les attraper je ne sais pas
exactement ce sur que je l'attrapé par
par vaux aérosols inhalé je dirais pas
ça mais je ne fais partie des
possibilités
cette possibilité le gouvernement
l'avait déjà écarté un mois avant que le
docteur pius ne soient infectés et
éprouvée été discutée notamment par nina
spécu que le masque de procédure était
suffisant qui avait pas besoin de 20 95
je pense que c'est un enjeu que je dois
appeler le clip pour moi qui ai réglé
mais ce n'est pas le cas ailleurs
depuis des mois les américains et les
européens recommandent en priorité des
masques de type n 95 en présence de cas
suspectés ou confirmés et à l'automne
plusieurs autorités sanitaires vont
reconnaître un risque de transmission
par aérosol
[Musique]
au québec c'est seulement à la fin de
janvier 2021 que le gouvernement décide
que l' appareil de protection
respiratoire peut être envisagée mais
seulement après avoir pris toutes les
autres mesures aient utilisé un
algorithme avec cette étape pour prendre
une décision
c'est comme si l'internet est donné
comme une récompense c'était un beau
bulletin toutes les autres mesures le
droit en 95 trop compliqué ces
directives ne resteront pas en place une
semaine plus tard la cn insisté décide
finalement d'agir elle exige maintenant
un masque de type n 95 pour tout
travailleur en zones chaudes
le gouvernement est forcée d'aller plus
loin
le compromis des n95 seront permis dans
des milieux ayant deux cas ou plus la
victoire est douce amère pour la
chercheuse geneviève marchand
ça arrive peut-être vous avez un peu
tard dans tout dans toute cette crise là
on aurait aimé ce que ça arrive plus tôt
moi je veux dire mieux vaut tard que
jamais
nos recherches révèlent qu'après un
premier avis en avril son institut a
encore écrit deux fois à la cn insisté
pour recommander le port du n95 le
nombre préoccupant de travailleurs de la
santé infectées depuis l'envoi du
premier avis nous et c'est a réitéré
l'importance d'appliquer le principe de
précaution en rehaussant le niveau de
protection respiratoire et le 14 octobre
l'institut affirme que le port d'un
appareil de protection respiratoire est
nécessaire dans tous les endroits où il
y a plusieurs cas de kobe 19 suspects et
ou confirmés la cnss t nous répond
qu'elle avait les mains liées par l'
ordonnance de juin du docteur arruda par
courriel le ministère de la santé lui
qui nous dit que l' ordonnance visait à
préserver les n 95 pour les travailleurs
les plus exposés et qui sait aussi
toujours fié à la science mais plusieurs
de ces arguments ont été rejetés cette
semaine par le tribunal administratif du
travail
le juge conclut que le gouvernement a
sous-estimé le risque de transmission
aérienne de lakovic 19 et qu'il aurait
dû appliquer le principe de précaution
il ordonne à même d'élargir encore
davantage l'accès au n95
je pense qu'ils l appareil de protection
respiratoire peut symboliser ce qui
aurait été comme une tape dans le dos
aux gens du réseau de dire on vous
fournit ce qu'on est capable de vous
fournir de plus de plus poussées pour
vous protéger parce que vous en valait
la peine pour prendre tous les moyens à
notre disposition pour protéger les gens
[Musique]